all right
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to prepare like a
pro it's uh me once again woman
grandmaster italia cervantes and today
we're going to be
uh taking a look at a topic that i find
quite interesting uh we can take it more
of it as a discussion right than just me
explaining something and you guys
reacting to it
um i kind of want us to talk about
these two examples they're from
uh two games of mine during a tournament
that i played in may
called the continental the absolute
continental
championship it's a it's kind of a very
big deal it's a qualifying tournament
the top four spots get
a spot at
the world cup so it was very competitive
i finished 12 actually which is not bad
i started 30th 31st in the ranking
something like that
and
this
this game right here
is
kind of the start of a learning process
that i had during the tournament
and it has to do a lot with realizing
your mistakes especially during a
tournament when you don't have as much
time as
you know in the process of preparation
to
fix whatever is wrong because you
literally have a game next day right so
uh it's very important to always analyze
your games even a little bit after you
finish
a game at a tournament and then
figure out what went wrong and be
conscious of it for the next couple of
rounds
right
i don't know if you guys have ever had
moments like this
where you kind of realize during a
tournament that something is going wrong
or that something is not working out
for example
recently
i played the u.s juniors u.s junior
girls as some of you may know
and what maybe you don't know is that
right after like two days after i
decided to play this
uh round robin i am norm tournament
and during the first three or four
rounds i actually felt like i was
playing pretty bad and in this show in
my game i was missing moves and i was
taking too long and i was a little
self-conscious in my variations and all
of that
so
i feel like especially after round four
there was kind of this shift
of
what do i do to fix it right and most of
the times i feel like it's better to
acknowledge whatever problem you notice
while playing your tournament then
pretend that everything is fine to put
yourself in a good mood i feel like that
doesn't work at least for me never ends
up working so probably for the best
um
is to acknowledge
the
the mistakes right and see
see how to fix them
so for example during this tournament
that i was talking about the important
tournament i decided to play more
practical i didn't
go into such depth and complex
calculations
and i tried to just play as easy breezy
as i could and make my positions you
know just very natural where my moves
come to mind
simply and it ended up working i kind of
saved the tournament
and it was all good so um i want to talk
about this specific game and this
example right here i think you guys are
able to see the position from the white
side right now and it is white to move
but before anything i kind of want to
ask you guys your opinion
um on on this position and what you
think
is going on right so like based on
material at first and king safety
placement of the pieces how active the
pieces are and then pawn structure
obviously
so
anyone in the chat or here i guess feel
free to
um to just say whatever you think about
this position it doesn't have to be
super concrete you don't have to give
like full-on variations at the moment
but just kind of like your thoughts on
how the position looks so far
and
i guess like if you were white pieces
here how would you continue
this came from uh from a king's indian
by the way as weird as that may sound uh
it comes from a kings indian a sandwich
variation where i allow my opponent to
play c takes d4 knight takes c4 then we
got kind of a marozzi setup
and there was a pawn on c4 pawn on d6 i
played c5 they got traded off
and that's how we got here
so any thoughts
i should cover this
just to make sure
um
yes so
one person is saying that white seems
kind of stuck
i guess i could agree with that like our
the white pieces
it's not so clear to see where they're
going to next right um i feel like this
bishop right here at least for the
moment it does a really good job at
closing up the file
and
not allowing you know any pressure to
happen especially on the knight on c3
right
um
but can the the question is can the
bishop stay there right because black
also has some ideas of retreating with
the knight
the the thing is that if either knight
goes to d7 you gotta take into
consideration uh oops you gotta take
into consideration we should take c7
right look if the knight goes back so
there's a lot of calculation there's a
little bit of calculation involved as
well
another person is saying i like a4 to
create some weaknesses in the queen side
that's very interesting yeah so a4
trying to provoke some
some issues on that side
i guess the main question yeah the main
question is just how
how does white continue in this turn and
they have to play very fast
because
soon after you know
black is going to try and get rid of
this bishop and if this bishop falls the
whole position kind of
crumbles a little bit
so in terms of evaluation
this position right now is at about
equal white has to play very precisely
and move like a4 makes a lot of sense
but there is kind of one move here from
white that
deserves a lot of
a lot of analysis right because it's
very immediate
um maybe you guys can try and
and give me your thoughts
i in this position i had seen this line
coming from a few months ago
and i decided to play pawn to f4
right pawn to f4 you guys are mentioning
it
yes so
after a point for
you know serious calculation
needs to needs to be done because for
example if something like knight to d7
certainly the white position can be very
good right
something like pawn to
pawn to e5 let's say
kind of
you know
brings some
some attention and if the knight goes
back
knight to d5 right and
all of a sudden there are some issues
here
and the queen of course
so it's very important to
to
still be realistic in the position right
and try to understand what is going on
the thing is that black has a very very
nice sequence
that allows them to escape these
problems and i didn't realize this once
i decided to play pawn to f4
there is a way
here that black can start to
to escape
the issue so for example after knight d7
pawn to e5 which is what ended up
happening
how can we kagan black continue i'm
going to flip the board to see if it's
easier
because at least for this turn
it's kind of a question of black to move
but
are you do you think that black is
completely doomed or is there
some resource
i like how one comment says maybe a 4
but it seems sharp yeah it is actually
quite sharp so
try and figure out
how this ends
for black
and like i said it can be more of a
discussion so just i guess whatever
your thoughts are
um about the position feel free to
to voice them
but certainly there was a lot going on
that i didn't notice at first
and it was when it was my turn to make a
move and to make a decision
and i was actually seeing all of the
resources going on
it was too late so
yeah
okay so we have one comment that says
knight takes c5
and after a pawn takes
bishop takes f6
what do you guys think is this uh is
this enough
uh for
is this enough for for black or
are they doomed after
let's say knight d1 or pontex
the thing is that the moves kind of flow
naturally here
for black right
oh wait someone is saying knight g4
followed by knife
oh 94 followed by 95.
i feel like that's a little slow knight
g4 i'm going to
uh just take it i think either with
knight or bishop
actually the the correct variation is
knight c5 plane takes bishop takes and
the question is after it takes takes
how does the position
evaluate right
obviously you know the two nights are
hanging at the moment
and that's a very big issue that white
has to deal with
but not only that the pawn on a2
is
probably gonna fall
soon after
and
black has a bishop pair
right
so it makes it very difficult for white
to even try and keep some control of the
position where black when black has a
bishop pair
especially with these two pawns in some
sort of end game or in the future it's
going to be quite hard to
to
keep the pawns tamed right even if white
has a piece more
and it's
very uncomfortable how everything
turns out because
it's not like the queen can move over to
the d-file and try to help out the
pieces or help this knight here on e3
it's a little difficult to
to save it all so yeah you guys are
saying knight to
knight to d1 um
and that's kind of what ended up
happening in the game
so after takes takes i would the white
pieces played knight cd1 it's kind of a
transposition
but after bishop to d4
takes queen takes
c5 we ended up getting this and it's
very hard for me to defend this knight
right here and of course um black is
threatening takes and then takes with
the rook on c2
so after queen takes c5 rook takes c5
takes takes
you may think okay we traded a couple of
pieces like there's no way that white is
under any risk right now but the
position is still so much easier to play
from the practical point of view for
for black
because
not only is this been very difficult to
get out of
black is threatening right now rook
takes d1 bishop takes e3 and bishop
takes a2
so there are a lot of threats happening
at the moment there's also rookie rook
d2 right with the idea of attacking both
the bishop and the pawn on a2 and
i feel like this one right here you can
kind of
take it for a loss spawn already
um
so this is how the game played out and
i'm just gonna show you a few more moves
we don't need to see the whole game
because my opponent actually gave me
some chances and we got to an opposite
color bishop
end game and he was always winning for
him but i don't know why he allowed me
to
to to even get to that point but after
king f2 bishop takes a2 knight c3 bishop
e6
95 bishop d4
position of a stone just became
very very uncomfortable he went back
with the bishop 2
to
c8 trying to put it on b7 relocate it
and keep everything under control we
ended up moving the pieces around and it
was around the time where
uh we were getting closer to
time control
so both of us were a little bit low on
time there were a few moments where
maybe i could have tried to hold on but
it was just very difficult and as you
can see here um this bishop can come
here and here
and
the position is just almost unbearable
right so after knight to c5 even bishop
to
f5 and suddenly you know i can't keep
the control of everything that are just
too many threats right
the two bishops are very annoying that's
why usually i prefer playing with the
two bishops but of course here i had to
play against them
and yeah it was just
uh completely losing for uh for white
and i went on to lose this game it was
my only loss from the tournament
i scored like eight out of 11
8 and a half out of 11 something like
that
um
but
yeah it was 8 out of 11. but
the thing is that
the thing is that you know after i
finish this game
i realize okay this f4 right here
it was you know a little bit rushed
maybe i could have tried to play more
calm like rook d1 or something and it
would have been
probably for the best
but in the way that i played i
overextended a little bit there is a
saying i mentioned it during
u.s juniors in one of the interviews
actually there is a saying that f4 is
always wrong
um which is a shame because it's also my
favorite move to do in most of positions
um i like having space so i like playing
f4 i play the four pawns attacking as a
king's indian sometimes it's just like a
move that i like to do but i do realize
that oftentimes even when it has you
know the best intentions of kicking
pieces back
it creates too many weaknesses and
um after i finish this game i talked to
my coaches and
they were telling me you know be careful
over extending moving your pawns too
much keep this in mind for future rounds
right and at first i was just you know
kind of listening as normal like sure um
yeah i'm probably gonna keep an eye on
that but then one of my coaches said
something
kind of funny
um he said
uh what did he say oh yeah
he said um
try to play like carpool what would
karpov do in this position i was just
looking and i mean i wasn't looking at
him because i was texting him but i was
just like what do you mean like i can't
play like hyper if i could i would do it
but obviously i'm not cockpit right
um but he just kind of wanted me to play
more
i guess
prophylactic and try to
slowly but surely squeeze the life out
of my opponent rather than
rather than overextend too much or rush
things out in a position
so
i kind of kept that in mind and i feel
like it's it's very important you know
when you play your games especially in
in official tournaments
always important to keep in mind what
your weaknesses are too right and be
very conscious of them and make sure
that you're not
falling into their trap right while
while you're playing
getting carried away by the moment
so i kept this in mind
um and next game i was black pieces i
won my game relatively easy i was
playing um like much lower rated
opponent
and
then
i was white pieces again
against another international master by
the way this guy that i played was an
international master and in the next
round i was playing another
international master right with the
white pieces so i was thinking okay i'm
gonna try and
not overextend
and i'm gonna try to maneuver my pieces
as best as i can
and
watch out for any f4 that i could do
because uh probably it's not going to be
good
play like carpool so that's what i've
been doing wrong yeah i mean um
everybody has a different style i just
tried to be more conscious of my mistake
in this um
in this specific tournament
but
yeah if i could play like carpet every
day i would um
like without any questions right it's
not really
i just don't think i can it was just
kind of a
remembering and most points are in this
game like oh be very careful not to
overextend how to take away
uh opportunities from the opponent right
and that led us onto
this game so pawn to d4 pawn to g6 c4
bishop g7 they're actually from the same
country they play similar openings i
don't know if that's just a thing but um
yeah
it was amazing to see how the two
bishops and the pawn were better than
the two knights in the bishop yeah like
the pair of bishop was just so strong in
that position and it looked exactly how
it needed to look
um
yeah
but okay uh knight c3 pawn to c5 pawn to
d5 usually those openings um tend to be
quite fine for
for white even if the pawns are doubled
uh black gave away their best
piece or their best bishop right for
doubling up the two pawns right here and
oftentimes you know the main line is
going pawn to f5 it uh
controls a little bit of space i want to
play knight f6 next turn and there are
even lines where white plays with e4
pawn takes f3
you get something like this some files
in the center are open
and there are even ideas of bishop d3
bringing the bishop to h6 if the knight
develops playing h4h5
position just tends to be practically
better
easier to play for white
so
yeah
however my opponent didn't play like
this with f5 he played with e5 and i was
a bit surprised because i never seen
this move before but if you think about
it it kind of it kind of makes sense
because he's gonna try and put the pawns
on the opposite collar as the bishop
that he has right so he gave up the dark
square bishop it makes sense to put the
pawns on dark square now that that
bishop is gone so the squares are
covered and the other bishop you know
just has a freeway to work in the
opposite color
but after pawn to e5 pawn to e4 d6
bishop d3 i was just trying to make some
normal moves
knight d7 knight e2 i feel like there
are a few different setups that you can
use um you can also put the knight on f3
and that is completely fine personally i
am a sandwich player so i'm so used to
putting my knight on e2 playing with the
pawn on f3 and then seeing what happens
but after knight to e2 queen to e7
castle
uh knight two of six everything looks
quite normal so far f4 it might look a
little bit tempting um kind of but
the main issue is that after takes and
let's say
bishop takes
the square on e5 will always be
available for this knight to jump to and
it will be an outpost and since there is
no longer a pawn on the f file you won't
be able to get away with f4 right
obviously they can't do it right now
because there is bishop to g5
uh but let's say after something like
h6
it doesn't have to be quite immediate
black can even actually black can't even
probably do something like castle play
king g7 try to put the knight here but
even after something like h6 and i can
have ideas already of jumping over 2
to e5
not even h6 you can even consider
something like knight g495 right
and
you know long term it's gonna be
difficult for y2
to
regain control of the position where
white where black has such a strong
knight on e5
um so i decided to just play with f3
kind of keeping it tame king to d8 and i
mean honestly i had my opponent was kind
of blitzing out all of those moves and i
hadn't even considered king to d8 i feel
like it's not really my fault like into
the a just seems so unnatural
uh but he clearly just wants to put the
king on the on the queen side
keeping it safe
uh
maybe you know if he had castle the king
short he would have to deal with my
bishop right and some weaknesses around
the king
so he probably didn't want to go through
that
um and he might use the queen side the
kingside in the future for some ideas of
g5 g4
uh maybe breaking open
my my castle king
and try to get some counter play on this
side for the lack of space that they
have in the center
so i think that this was the idea that
my opponent had
and after i came to the aid
um i was still a little bit confused
trying to understand what my plan was i
decided to go bishop to e3 maybe it's
not the most necessary of most
but it's still fine qc7
queen d2 knight to h4
i played pawn to a4 my opponent played
pawn to a5
and here you know
so far up until this point i have been
spending like about five to ten minutes
on each move just trying to understand
what the ideas are because i feel like
most of my moves up until now have been
isolated right so like bishop b3 is an
isolated move a4 has a completely
different idea so
now i'm trying to think a little bit
deeper
about the position and try to understand
what is my plan going to be so
it was at this moment right that it kind
of put back into my mind the idea of
okay
what would would do here and
you know if karpov was playing this
position he would probably
uh severely punish black for
giving white all of this space
and
just keep on pushing the pieces back
right into worse squares to the point
where black gets completely suffocated
so
how should white continue in this
position
if they want to have some sort of idea
like that
okay we got one suggestion you're okay
av1
g3 comes to mind
but it's hard to plan to find a plan for
white for sure
there's one g4 two people are saying g4
i guess it's kind of like yeah which
side of the board do you want to play
because certainly you can play something
like rook to b1
um it's kind of one of it's one of the
moves that i was considering in this
position
but i wasn't sure if it was
you know
if it was gonna do anything because the
pawn is obviously going to b6 right
from from black
it does make sense you know you bring
the rook over to a semi-open file
we march the king to the b file for
safety
we might i mean we might do a few things
before that
we might do a few things before that
bishop2h6 i feel like that moves makes
sense
um but there is a way that you can
uh
there is a way that you can
like
you know make it a cohesive sequence of
moves right
f4 could be fun i don't know if it's
accurate though i feel like a florence
even if it's you know even if it works i
feel like it's doing what black wants
what black wants
white to do right because after f4 you
know before white kind of had most of
the controlling the position now it can
be a fight for control right
so i feel like this is what black wants
the position is very locked up
but it's certainly white who has the
more of the control right
you guys keep wanting to play f4 and
that makes me feel better because
like i said um f4
it's kind of a move that i really like
making but
obviously
there are some consequences in this
specific pawn structure the pawn on e5
actually helps us right because it
doesn't allow black to put a knight
there
so
all right let's see what happened
rook to b1
pawn to v6
so it does make sense just keep the
keep the position you know
kind of
collected i feel like bringing the rook
to b1 we mention it
play pawn to v6
just kind of getting things ready right
and
now
i still say g4 okay well
we might need to go for g4
the point of g4 is very interesting
actually so there are some
that are some some
things that need to be kind of
calculated
but overall it's not too bad right like
for example it's not like our king is
going to check get checkmate after we
play pawn to b4
so pawn to
punto g4 sorry
it's not like our key is going to get
checkmated after it right we'd still
have a lot of pieces around knight to r4
doesn't quite work because after it
takes takes takes bishop gets a good
diagonal and the difference is that
whenever this knight goes to e5 we do
have pawn to f4 right so eventually
something like not that something like
bishop g3 and f4 and e5 is coming
so not just you know upon up but also
white has an initiative
and in the game my opponent decided to
play knight to g7
and then bishop to h6 right
and the whole point of this variation is
to make sure that
after the knight goes away
they don't have pawn to h5 because then
they start fighting for counterplay
right but if i play bishop to h6 i shut
everything down uh there's not going to
be any h5 there's not going to be any f5
either uh because after something like
pawn takes takes bishop takes i
eliminate the
the defender of the pawn and i'm gonna
play bishop takes f5 put my knight on g3
position is okay
uh
it's not enough
compensation for sacrificing a pawn here
for
for black so
kind of the whole point is to keep on
restricting the position and what is
going on
um if the knight has gone to f6 i feel
like something similar would happen i
will probably bring my bishop over to h6
just to make sure that things are
completely shut down
and the good thing about knight to
knight to f6 is that i also have ideas
of g5 right so you can i can't even
consider something like here and right
here and whenever black tries to play
like h6 trying to open things up i can
just take and i have enough pieces
protecting that pawn right
so
oh yes if you want to play something
like this in bishop h6 you can't really
play knight g8 to kick out my bishop
because i have bishop to g7 funny enough
and it just goes on to show how
how
tied up the pieces are
i gave away the idea when you when i
said play like carpool
uh
i mean then remind yourself when i
returned to play like carpool and you're
gonna give yourself the hint
um
but yeah so g4 knight to g7 was played
bishop h6
rook to g8
knight to g3 makes sense controlling
even more the square here on f5 and the
whole point now is just going to keep on
restricting black and making sure that
they don't have any pawn break right
because then our the position of our
king becomes a little bit more weakened
so we just got to make sure that we
don't allow any pawn break and then the
position should be fine
bishop to a6 rook to f2 i was just kind
of making moves
going around
rook f2 is always helpful it just
controls the second file the second rank
sorry and um
yeah just make sure that nothing is
going on and when i play h4 there is not
going to be any f5 right because i have
like bishop to g5 and
everything is under control
surrogate was played king to g2 rook 2
h1 just bringing the pieces over to
where they make sense
knight 28 and
now it's kind of about time
like obviously you can spend a couple of
moves maneuvering around but now it's
time to come up with the second phase of
the plan right which pawn break do you
want to do
do you still want to play a 4
do you want to play h5
do you want to play pawn to g5 so you
start taking these things into
consideration
and for whenever
whatever pawn break
you are thinking of having here on the
king side there's one piece of ours that
we might need to get out of the way
first right
and how how do we do that
yes you should still be scared that f4
is giving black to e5 square
again carpool style we don't need to
have a pawn break right now we can keep
on preparing things until our position
is the most optimal
again you don't need to give me like a
like a tactical variation or anything
just kind of like what your ideas are in
the position and
what you think is the best chance here
for
for white and how to continue or if you
just have any questions about the
position
i'm willing to answer them so
just feel free to voice whatever you
think is going on right now as if it was
your own game
move king to the queen side how does
that sound moving the king all the way
over to the queen side does that make
sense or is that a waste of time
what do you guys
think i know there were some mentions of
it before
i am not taking challenges right now
wrong stream yeah i'm doing a lecture i
already took challenges from 2pm central
time till 4pm
i do play the people almost every day
but this is more of a lecture
you want to play h5 i think but you need
to move the h6 bishop first that's a
good observation
black cannot do anything so we have time
okay
um
all right so actually
uh
around this time is where i started
coming up with the idea of bringing the
king over to the queen side
and i feel like it does make a lot of
sense just making sure that
um the key won't be in any crossfire
right for whatever
pawn break i decide to do on the
on the on the king side so again to f1
we maneuver we just shuffle pieces
around
or more like he chuckled pieces around
and i brought my king over to b3
bishop to c8 so now is when you
seriously start considering the pawn
breaks right we had some brief mentions
that about h5 and it does look very nice
right playing h5 and after g5 wow then i
get such a beautiful square here on f5
the thing is that after queen to d8 this
bishop right here is a little bit weird
right there is no immediate way to go
after it there's no immediate way to
to attack it
but it it doesn't feel nice just leaving
the bishop here on on h7 right so you
could technically start considering
bringing the bishop back and then after
something like bishop here let's say
playing h5 right this is very similar to
something that ended up happening later
on in the game by the way
uh but the thing is that i was looking
at positions like this
and i was just thinking
okay the position is too close like what
do i do next
right because you have beautiful pieces
right you have the beautiful knight on
f5 but what does it attack i have no
more pawn breaks everything is closed
completely
and my opponent can just play like
knight g7 try to trade up the night
um
well i guess not right now because
there's gonna be knight h6 but they
don't even have to trade off the nights
like i don't have a i don't have a clear
follow-up plan
right because i already closed it off a
little too much
but it was an idea that i had
and of course f4 is always kind of in
the back of your mind but you know after
it takes takes knight g5 knight e5 the
pawn on g4 is under attack then the
knight on e5 is very strong and if you
think about it my king is not super safe
the position just opens up right
so i have to be very careful with how
much i'm willing to
to give in to this position and i think
f4 is not the call
the other thing is pawn to g5 right
and that's the only the other pawn break
my main concern with this one is that
um if the if the f file opens my pawn on
f3 is is it gonna be weak right that was
my main question while i was um taking a
look at this position i wasn't entirely
sure of course there is no pawn to f5
because i can just take everything
and
you know there's enough protection
but i was just you know just thinking
like takes if bishop takes or pawn takes
i kind of like phonetics because it
opens up this file unfortunately leaves
my bishop stuck here on h2
on h6 so i wasn't sure if that was worth
it there might be some pressure here on
f3
uh so i think that g5 certainly white
can try and play but there might need to
be some preparation beforehand so
in this position i guess you know
positions around this one because white
can kind of
move pieces back and forth
what would be the next step of the plan
like plan number three i guess for this
destructor for white
we gotta regroup some stuff
so how should i continue
and like i said it's more of a
discussion so just feel free to
to say whatever
double rooks and have more control over
the f file okay yeah i guess we could
double rooks in the file
black weakness is h7 the thing is how do
we get to h7 right because it feels like
black will always play pawn to g5
and it's gonna keep things closed
maybe put the bishop on h3 i like where
that's going
oh after g5 well the thing is that we
really have to time out g5 correctly
because if they take and we take with
the pawn our bishop will always be stuck
on h6 so we can't really attack h7
so
i mean we can take back with the bishop
but then the h file is not open so
i was looking at all of this during the
game and it was so hard to
to like find a sequence that actually
worked right
so
there is no immediate pawn break that
you know gives an advantage to white
but
there is some maneuvering going around
an idea of bishop f1 bishop to h3
uh was was considered and i think it
does make sense
however maybe there is a piece that
should go through f1 first
another piece i should say
that goes through f1 first
yeah good good job sean the king is on
b3 do you have any ideas now on how to
improve the position for white because
none of the pawn breaks work right now
there are two pieces that you can that
you can regroup
okay i like where you guys are going
with your ideas
i'm just going to give it a couple
more seconds so
more people can chime in and
give and give a thought or if you want
to just give a plan you know like a
like a three or four move plan
feel free to to do that too
okay so we mentioned bring the bishop to
east to h3
and you guys are also talking about
bringing the
the um
the knight to e3
i feel like that makes a lot of sense
well the b file is open and then i can
get to v5 and there is potential for
bishop a3 bishop before
sacrifice wow um i didn't even consider
that i did think about bringing the
knight to e5
and i think it's one of the possible
ideas you know
um
i wasn't exactly sure what the knight
was going to do on b5
because the king can just move to like
b7 and then i i wasn't sure
what else the knight does on b5 it's
kind of similar to when we were talking
about h5 g5 knight five it looks very
beautiful in an outpost but i don't know
exactly what it does
however you know you guys are right in
the sense and then i can go to f1 at
first right so let's say knight to f1 um
black keeps moving pieces around knight
e3 bishop c8 now we can do the second
part of the plan right
um
we already improved our knight it was
more of in the edge towards the edge of
the board now it's more towards the
center it has the potential to jump to
c2a3b5 whenever we wanted to
and it also
keeps on controlling f5
and
[Applause]
it doesn't get in the way of the of the
g file right especially if we're going
to open up some files with some phone
breaks
um
so you have knight takes g5
i don't know what you mean with knight
takes g5
but
oh oh put in the knight on h3
i i think i thought about putting the
nine on h3 but i i feel like it's too
awkward for the knight
um if we play h5 they're gonna play g5
and i don't think knight takes works
there are just too many pieces from
black uh
uh protecting everything so i don't
think
i don't think 92 know g1 at h3 is the
best plan but you know
it's not
the thing about this position is that
it's it's not super
um
it's not super decisive right what you
do at the exact moment you can take your
time when maneuvering the pieces around
right so for example this knight just
came to a slightly better square here on
e3
uh the next part of the plan of course
is going to be taking care of this
bishop right here oh another thing that
i forgot to mention for the for the
moment the knight does support uh c4 but
the knight on e3 also supports c4 so
whenever the bishop is on a on a6 or
something
our pawn won't be under any trouble
while we're transferring our bishop to
h3
so for example just bishop to f1 right
now
and all of a sudden it becomes a little
bit
hard for black to know what to do right
let's say king b7 bishop to h3
do you
enjoy getting into super close positions
or was this intentional that's a very
funny question
because
you guys are gonna see the end of this
game in a few moves right
and
i was messaging my coach like
i felt very fancy you know playing this
position because you know it looks very
karpovian and i look i it almost looks
like i know what i'm doing
but in reality i was freaking out i was
actually lower on time than my opponent
he was just playing like kim b1787 and
he was doing nothing and i was the one
that had to come up with a plan there
was so much pressure on me i didn't know
i didn't know how to play out the
position entirely
so it depends um it had like it's fun
parts where it's only me who can do
something here and
and overall you know my position is
better
objectively
but at the same time it's hard being the
one that comes up with the plans right i
feel like the more you practice these
positions the more you enjoy them
because
i would say that if black
you know if white doesn't like playing
these positions
black is gonna hate it
way way more right so
um yeah
why is it white the only one who can do
stuff well black doesn't have any pawn
breaks right so f5 is never working i
have way too many pieces
um
controlling it right uh black also can't
play g5 right because then i'm going to
bring my knight over to
2f5 open up the h file and i'm going to
be the one
calling the shots and essentially i just
have a lot more space in the position
the black pieces are a lot more awkward
you can see that my pieces have more
freedom to move than the black pieces
and um
that's why objectively it's a little bit
better for white i would say like
between plus one and plus two more or
less
um but there are only so little ways
that you can improve your advantage
right and this is certainly one of them
bringing the knight over to e3 bringing
the bishop to 2 h3
and not only are you putting the pieces
on better squares but you also have some
um
some tactical ideas now right like
this pawn can come over to g5 and the
bishop can get into e6 right so that's a
that's a very strong square for the
for the bishop
um it's not super clear still
it's it's just a game right it's just a
game so there's still a lot to
to go off of
um but certainly white
is
one step closer to
to having that breakthrough that they
really need in this position to
seriously cease a vintage
so yeah
g5 makes room for the knight
to go to g4 yes as well so the knight
you know the knight can possibly go to
g4 in the future especially after
something like
takes takes right
um then i can even make it to g4
and overall you know it's kind of like
step by step slowly but surely white can
keep on building up the the position
um
which is quite fascinating it's just one
of those positions that you can analyze
and
find all of the different plans that are
being suggested
um and you can even you know put present
to the computer your own plans and see
how how they go right and if you're ever
not certain of a
of
of a variation that the computer is
giving to you you can play as the
opposite side right and see how it
refutes your ideas
so
yeah
exchanging the bishop on d3 for the
knight on d7 only makes f4 more
attractive you guys are really obsessed
with f4 and i feel like my point of this
lecture is to teach you to not play a
four
um
the the thing is that if you're going to
play f4 you might need to prepare it a
lot so you might want to put the rook on
d1 on f1 the queen on h2 so that when
you play four you take take with the
bishop put pressure here on d6
maybe then but most of the time you
won't have a breakthrough with e5 and e4
would be weak so i would say be very
very careful
when you are considering to break
through with f4 i feel like certainly
the
the idea that we have right here is to
play with g5
yeah
the thing is that i actually didn't see
any of this while i was playing i was
trying to find
i was trying to find what to do and i
just couldn't for the life of me find
what my idea was
this kind of takes me back to when i was
um a lot younger uh in 2015 i was
playing the the national
like some national scholastic
tournament here in the us in florida
and it was round three i was playing
this slightly higher rated guy we were
like 1900s okay i was playing this
slightly higher rated guy i have to go
back and look at the game but
essentially
i had a strategically better position i
think he had a backwards spawn and i had
you know files for my rooks open
and it was just one of those positions
where you double up the pieces you don't
allow your opponent to
push the palm forward
you put pressure on that pawn you create
a second weakness right and
slowly but surely it was almost like a
capablanca style game right like where
you just
put so much pressure on the opponent
and
win and i got to that position i knew
that there was one of those positions
that was really good for me and
i was just thinking okay i'm going to
i'm going to play like a pablanca i'm
going to play like karpov i'm going to
squeeze my opponent i'm going to play
like a gm i can do anything i believe in
myself i'm going to beat my opponent um
within like five moves somehow i
accidentally
allowed him to to push the backward
spawn trade a couple of pieces off and
then we got into an equal rook end game
so um i mean it wasn't a bad result a
draw against a higher rated guy was
still fine
but i was just thinking to myself like
wow
this is really not what i had not what i
had planned so
uh like i thought about that game you
know while i was playing this and it was
really hard for me to find another
breakthrough in this position but at
least i'm glad that i didn't give my
opponent any any chances you know for a
breakthrough themselves right
so
for example right here
um the the way that the game continued
was with k a3 bishop a6
um i had some considerations
of
uh like
i'm gonna show you so queen e3 knight c7
rogue h3 knight black queen c1
bishop b3 k97 i had some considerations
in this type of position
like rook a1 bishop
22
98
where is it exactly
there was something going on we just
shuffled pieces around
for a
very long time
but yes so i would say that around here
i was kind of considering h5
there's a knight on g3 and e3 make any
difference at the end but not only three
is just more centralized right you just
want your the pieces in the most optimal
squares
for when you are going to have a
breakthrough right then item g3 is not
necessarily bad maybe that's why the
idea of knight of 193 didn't come to me
but
um certainly
the knight on e3 just looks a lot better
and it also protects c4 it has the ideas
that we mentioned knight c2 knight e3
and b5 it just makes more sense overall
but in this specific position you know i
was looking for some position where i
could play h5 if my opponent plays g5 i
have knight f5 and i have the threat of
this pawn right here and knight to h2
right knight to h6 so i was kind of
looking at positions like this trying to
make this work i think right now there's
queen of fate which controls everything
but i was kind of trying to look for
positions like this right and the thing
that i realized is that sometimes
sometimes
even if i play pawn to h5 and my
opponent let's say ignores it doesn't
play pawn to g5 just does something else
um i don't know bishop here
after it takes text it's not so clear
because it almost looks like oh finally
i have i have the file right i can work
with this
but all of a sudden
all of a sudden it's not so clear what's
happening with this file and if i lose
control of this file
i am in big trouble right
so
i i wasn't sure how much i wanted to
open up the position either
because this also didn't look so
so nice for me i wasn't so tempted to go
into this variations
so finding that breakthrough that i
really wanted was quite difficult
and eventually i just played rook b1 and
played pawn to h5 g5 knight five this is
how kind of how the how the position
went
is bishop h6 an idea here
well yeah you can put the bishop on h6
that's what it was before
but at the same time whenever i play h5
and g5 i'm concerned that my bishop is
stuck here on h6
and at the same time i just couldn't
find where the breakthrough was i was
considering g5 but still um
it's not so clear oh after the file is
open so
[Music]
okay so we're saying like h5
let's say like h5 right here
we're talking about this kind of
something like take sticks
um rook here let's say
yeah you can put the bishop on h6 and i
even consider you know doing something
like this and then maybe even having
ideas of bishop of fate but i always
thought that okay what next like i
wasn't so
like super super sure of like
what was the next plan
i guess i could go for this and then try
to play like rook h3
and queen h2 or like rook uh rook h3
rook h2 and then bring the screen back
maybe it is possible
maybe it is possible but
it almost felt like
it was a lot
um
a lot of pressure going on and this
bishop h6 kind of gave me the same vibes
as bishop a7
in that famous cardboard game so i quite
like it
uh
yeah maybe now maybe now it is possible
maybe now it is possible
uh so maybe it's it's not so easy for my
opponent to just leave the h file open
i thought that he would have some
chances and a couple of times maybe it
was just my brains in ghosts
but i thought that it would be
i i i thought that it would be
maybe a little too difficult but i mean
of course the thing is that he can
always play g a g5 right
and suddenly it's not so clear
um
yeah so
the thing is that he has bone to g5 and
my neron f5 is beautiful right
it just looks amazing
uh but the thing is that after after
queen to a fade
just play like carpool piano after queen
to f8
it's not so clear what i do now i feel
like everything is too close now so
queen b2 i was trying to go for
something on the on the queen side
honestly i really wanted to make some
sort of bishop take c5 sacrifice work
but it never did so
um it never works so queen b5 my only
plan is try to get into my my only plan
is
try to get into c6 and maybe go after
this phone
but the thing is that i don't think that
is working
rook b1 can be two are great but the
knight on d7 is controlling it so if i
can get your knight on e6 and force a
trade
yeah but i can't really get my knight on
e6 that's the thing it's quite difficult
to
to piece these things out and the thing
is that the knight on a8 and funny
enough the knight on b8 it looks so
silly it looks so stupid the two knights
back there but
how do i break through there is no way
for me to
there's no way for me to to actually
break through
yeah you can put the pawn on h6 and play
knight knight g7 and knight e6 but the
bishop is just simply going to take it
and then rookie 7 probably takes and
it's not so clear what to do right so by
this point i was kind of realizing that
okay the position looks really good i
have a lot of space i have pressure on
the b file i have a monster knight on f5
but there's not
there's not any more i can do like the
position is just too locked up right so
after
uh i played rook to b2 bishop takes f5
pawn takes queen e8 bishop e4 my
opponent and i agreed to draw and this
is how the game ended
so
there was just uh not much more
that was
available by this point the position is
at about equal uh even if we trade
queens i don't have any breakthroughs
right like f4 never works
um h6 does nothing
i don't have
i don't have anything right so
yeah um
it's it's too locked yeah it's still
locked down and i can't do much
um uh yeah there is just
not much try and get away with ampersand
that is funny
um yeah so there's not much more that i
can do in this position right here it's
just kind of all too locked up
um however i felt a lot more proud of
myself playing this game
than
the
previous one
still you know this is an international
master it's not a it's not a
it's not a
not not not like a silly player or
anything um so i still felt very nice
making a draw against him and i felt
like i gave him a good fight
obviously i could have played even
better um
especially with that knight f193 bishop
f1 bishop h3 idea
uh but you know it was a very rich game
there were a lot of a lot of
interesting ideas and overall i felt
like i played quite nicely um
obviously yeah i could have played
better but i feel like i played quite
nicely i didn't make any blunders i
didn't let go of my advantage
in such a bizarre way so you know it's
kind of complex
but it's kind of complex but you know
still very interesting and i feel like
this is why you guys should certainly
try to go over whatever mistake you
do in tournaments and try to fix it and
um
you know probably the the the fastest
you're aware of it
the easier it is for you to
to
to fix that mistake so
certainly
it is a
thing to do while you're playing
tournaments especially like this one
because this one was one round per day
so i actually had the time to go over my
mistake and make sure that i wouldn't
do it again right and i think it was a
quite quite a nice tournament overall
um i drew against
uh 120 300 i drew like two grandmasters
uh one of them was gaske actually from
the united states
um yeah i feel like i played a pretty
decent tournament overall still the game
that i lost kind of paints me a little
bit it was the only game that i lost but
um
i think it was a very nice learning
experience though
yeah okay so that's kind of the end of
the
lecture for today thank you so much to
everybody that was here watching
uh feel free to
subscribe donate follow i don't know
whatever you want
and
i'll be taking care of more of the
lectures throughout the next two weeks
that's the grandmaster in residence
and
i'll see you guys
next time okay
bye bye
[Music]
you